[ __ ] Amal a Syrian refugee feels
devastated her daughter Sahar is to be
separated from her family in Denmark and
sent back to Damascus where she doesn't
know anyone
a young girl I cannot live alone in
Damascus
it's impossible
there are rapes and kidnappings
it's not safe at all
she just can't go there alone
the El refi family has been living in
abenra southern Denmark for six years
now
they found safety here from the civil
war in Syria
they are competitive when I came to
Denmark I wanted to start a new life
with my family here we came to this town
and I was happy
I thought I could stay here forever
until one day a letter from the
immigration office arrived saying her
residence permit has been revoked Sahar
appealed
Refugee appeals board decision on March
25 2022 on a complaint by Syrian citizen
Sahar Mahmoud El rifai
they say I was rejected my residence
permit won't be renewed
my mother and younger brother can stay
I'm the only one being expelled
foreign
foreign
Secondary School
she's a good student and has been
studying hard for her exams
I have lots of friends here I'm learning
languages and I've got a dream how I
want to be an engineer
my school is actually my second home
once the Danish government declared her
home City Damascus a safe area
everything changed Sahar is one of 400
syrians being told to leave Denmark the
immigration office did not grant us an
interview migration experts suspect a
policy of deterrence the Syrian refugees
having their residence permits withdrawn
is part of branding Denmark as a more
restrictive country when it comes to
Asylum and immigration policy although
Denmark doesn't actually have a return
agreement with Syria meaning that we
would draw residence permits but there
are no way of forcibly returning the
Syrian refugees to Syria and so Sahara
could be facing confinement in a
deportation camp in Denmark like this
one in alabeck
21 year old Syrian rahima Abdullah is an
activist and a youth representative on
the Danish Refugee Council she's
familiar with cases like sahars and
wants to help
it started at school where I had a
friend called Aya
one day she came to me and said she was
very scared because her residence permit
had not been extended because Denmark
had declared Damascus safe for a turn
so we went to the media that was our
only chance
you can't tell someone who's integrated
here that she has to go back to Damascus
the city is not safe
in eye's case the public effort finally
met with success last year she got
permission to stay since that time as
many as five syrians contact rahima per
day most of them women young men are not
expelled because they face conscription
in Bashir Assad's Armed Forces
sometimes I can't sleep at night because
I see such terrible cases and I take
them to heart
when I posted sahar's case on Facebook a
parliamentarian contacted me who wanted
to write about it
he might be able to help
sahar's memories of her own country are
mainly of War
is
when I was in Syria there were battles
and bombs here I feel much safer I have
my family here hey and this is where I
grew up
I'm a part of Danish Society
but now it appears that counts for very
little in the eyes of Danish law